(klaxons)
- Liberté!
(sirènes)
- Freedom!
(klaxons)
- Fuck Trudeau!
- La capitale fédérale
nene sera plus jamais la même.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ottawa occupé,
paralysé et secoué.
(klaxons)
Aujourd'hui, les camions
ont disparu, mais la ville
porte toujours les traces
du Convoi de la liberté.
La rue Wellington devant
le Parlement, désormais fermée
à la circulation, en est
le symbole le plus frappant.
Les souvenirs du convoi sont
encore vifs dans l'esprit
du conseiller municipalMathieu .
MATHIEU FLEURY, conseil
municipal, Ville d'Ottawa
- Ces véhicules-là sont
immenses, les klaxons.
Il faut se ramener à l'époque.
T'sais, il fait froid,
tu as pas les arbres,
quand tu klaxonnes, ça résonne
sur les bâtiments, l'odeur.
(vrombissement)
- Commerces fermés, citoyens
harcelés. L'élu, qui est père de
famille, a lui-même été menacé
après avoir suggéré de coupe
les sources de financement
aux manifestants.
- On a tous eu des menaces
par courriel, par appel,
par courrier. Puis moi, aiai eu
des menaces de visites chez nous
qui nous ont forcés à déménager.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ottawa se prépare àepeplonger
dans les déchirements de
cet épisode sans précédent.
Pendant six semaines, une
commission d'enqutete tentera
de déterminer si l'utilisation
des mesures d'urgence par
le gouvernement Trudeau pour
mettre fin à la contestation
était justifiée.
Le premier ministre,
des ministres, des policiers
et des organisateurs du convoi
devraient donner leur version
des faits.
(cris d'acclamation)
Début 2222, l'obligation
vaccinale pour les camionneurs
cristallise l'opposition
aux restrictions sanitaires.
Le gouvernement fédéral est
coconfronté à une manifestation
monstre dans la capitale
fédérale et des blocages
à des postes frontaliers.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le 12 février, les policiers
déplacent de force
les manifestants qui bloquent
le pont Ambassador entre
Windsor et Détroit.
Deux jours plus tard,
le gouvernement Trudeau
prend les anands moyens.
- Le gouvernement fédéral
invoque la Loi sur
les mesures d'urgence.
- La Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence est décrétée
pour la première fois depuis
son adoption en 1988.
Ottawa peut ainsi limiter
les mouvements, réquisitionner
des remorqueuses et geler
des avoirs. Encore aujourd'hui,
Justin Trudeau défendl'utilisats
pouvoirs spéciaux.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- On a utilisé les mesures
qui étaient proportionnelles
et nécessaires.
- Le recours à la Loi sur
les mesures d'urgence était
injustifié selon l'Association
canadienne des libertés civiles
qui conteste son utilisation
devant les tribunaux.
- C'est une loi assez sérieuse.
- La police a réussi à mettre
fin aux barrages de Windsor
et de Coutts en Alberta
sans les pouvoirs spéciaux
Le critère d'une urgence
nationale n'a pas été établi,
selon l'Association.
Me ALAIN BARTLEMAN, avatat,
Asso. can. des libertés civiles
- Que cette menace soit
suffisamment grave pour mettre
en mesure, pour menacer
la sécurité des Canadiens,
la sécurité de l'État.
Et, d'après l'Association,
ce seuil n'a pas été franchi.
- Justifié ou pas?
La commission d'enquête
doit tenter de répondre à
cette question dans un rappo
en février. Les conclusions
pourraient bien éclabousser
le gouvernement, mais présentent
aussi des risques politiques
pour le Parti conservateur.
- Freedom, not fear.
Truckers, not Trudeau.
- Le nouauau chef, Pierre
Poilievre, et certains députés
avaient appuyé le convoi.
Conservateurs et bloquistes
étaient opposés à l'utilisation
des pouvoirs d'urgence.
Le Bloc dénonce le manque
de transparence du gouvernement
Trudeau.
- Le ministère de la Sécurité
publique, là, des grandes pages
caviardées.
- Le comité parlementaire
qui se penche sur l'utilisation
des pouvoirs d'urgence
n'a pas eu accès à toute
l'information justifiant
ces mesures extraordinaires.
RHÉAL FORTIN, député,
Bloc québécois, Rivière-du-Nord
- Donc finalement, tout le monde
allègue un secret pour ne pas
répondre à nos questions.
- Il espère que la commission
d'enquête permettra
d'y voir plus clair.
- C'est là où on a vu
les remorqueuses commencer
à retirer...
- Aux yeux de Mathieu Fleury,
les pouvoirs spéciaux découlant
de la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence ont contribué au
retour à la normalité chez lui.
- En premier lieu, ça demeure
une ville qui doit être capable
de vivre et puis de protéger ses
résidents et ses entreprises.
- Entre le sort d'une ville
assiégée, une gestion policière
déficiente et certaines libertés
individuelles suspendues,
la crise était complexe.
Reste que le gouvernement
Trudeau devra tout de même
justifier l'utilisation
des mesures d'urgence
et le précédent qu'il a créé.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et j'en discute avec Daniel
Thibault à Ottawa. Daniel,
tout ça, c'est très politique,
est-ce que c'est risqué cet
exercice pour Justin Trudeau?
- Il y a toujours des risques.
Louis l'évoquait dans
son reportage, Céline.
Bon pour Justin Trudeau d'abord,
c'est la conclusion du juge
Rouleau à la fin de lnqnquête,
c'est que le gouvernement
n'avait pas les justifications
nécessaires pour invoquer la
Loi sur les mesures d'urgence.
Ça sera citée par ses opposants
comme une autre preuve de son
manque de jugement, un peu comme
les vacances sur l'île de l'Aga
Khan, ou''''affaire SNC-Lavalin.
D'un autre côté, il y a
un risque aussi pour Pierre
Poilievre, qui a été, on l'a vu
dans les images, étroitement
associé à ce qu'on voit là.
Il y a fort à parier que
les témoins du gouvernement vont
souligner, même si de façonsubt,
pour la rappeler au public,
peut-être pour la cimenter
dans la mémoire des électeurs
qui ne s'en souviendieient pas.
Ceci dit, ce sont des risques
qui sont limités et ceux
qui étaient d'accord avec
le gouvernemt t Trudeau vont
demeurer d'accord. Ceux qui
s'opposaient à la Loi sur les
mesures d'urgence vont continuer
de s'y opperer. Au bout du
compte, ça demeure un exercice
hautement politique qui se tient
d'abord et avant tout,
faut-il le rappeler,
parce que la loi l'impose.
- Et Pierre Poilievre a présenté
d'ailleurs son cabinet fantôme
aujourd'hui par communiqué,
il n'a pas parlé
aux journalistes.
- Non, voil. . C'est un peu...
c'est un peu devenu la marque de
commerce de Monsieur Poilievre
depuis son accession à la tête
du Parti conservateur. Outre
cet incident dans le foyer
de la Chambre des communes,
où prise de bec avec
un journaliste l'avait forcé
à répondre à deux questions.
Il n'a pas rencontré la presse
depuis qu'il est à la tête
du Parti conservateur.
Pas rencontré de journisistes.
Pas de grande entrevue non plus,
donc, aujourd'hui, ça s'est fait
par communiqué.
- Et des surprises dans
ce cabinet fantôme?
Qu'est-ce que vous retenez?
- Beaucoup de monde : 51 postes
de porte-paroles, qui feront
face à 38 ministres du côté
du gouvernement Trudeau,
donc pas mal de monde.
Il y a une vingtaine de porte-
paroles adjoints qui s'ajoutent
à ça. Quelques nominations
intéressantes; Dominique Viens,
qui est porte-parole adjointe
Femmes et Égalité des genres
et Jeunesse. L'ex-ministre
provincial au Québec, on aurai
pu s'attendre à ce qu'elle ait
un poste un peu plus important.
Joël Godin, qui, durant la
course, avait menacé de quitter
le ptiti si Pierre Poilievre
le dirigeait, demeure porte-
parole des Langues officielles.
Richard Martelququi a fait du
bon travail sur Hockey Canada,
demeure au Sport et au
Développement économique
du Québec. Attardons-nous sur
la dernière Gérard Deltell, qui
est porte-parole Environnement,
Changentnts climatiques,
nomination intéressante dans
ce cas-là, qu'est-ce qu'on doit
y lire? Bien peut-être que
Monsieur Poilievre voulait
un bon communicateur dans
un dossier qui est généralement
épineux pour les conservateurs.
Monsieur Deltell pourrait au
surplus être appelé à contribuer
à l'élaboration de la prochaine
plateforme verte des
conservateurs, donc avoir
une influence. Ça pourrait
aussi être un couteau à double
tranchant, parce qu'il pourrait
devoir se retrouver sur le
terrain au Québec, à défendre
des idées qui ne seraient
peut-être pas tout à fait
populaires auprès de certaines
portions de l'ecectorat.
- Oui, alors, à suivre.
Merci Daniel.
- Absolument, au revoi